I don't know anybody who thinks that
feedback conversations work whether
that's in your family or with your
friends or in your organization whether
you have it to give or something
unsolicited advice or criticism or
offhand comments or your performance
review are being aimed at you the
feedback conversations are dreaded and
often dismissed and so what's
interesting is that the usual response
is to teach givers how to give more
effectively so organizations send all
their managers and to teach them how to
give more skillfully and more
persistently as individuals we wait
around for that perfect giver to show up
who we trust who has the credibility and
experience to actually be helpful to us
whose opinion we actually want rather
than all of those who offer them to us
unsolicited and it occurred to us that
actually we've been going about this
backwards focusing on teaching givers
how to give as a push model of learning
right I figure out what you need to
learn and I push you to learn it and it
occurred to us that actually it's the
receiver who's in charge of what they
take in what sense they make of it and
whether and how they choose to change
doesn't really matter how authoritative
or powerful or even skillful the giver
is the real leverage here is in teaching
all of us particularly those of us who
are in leadership or who are parenting
or in relationship with other people
that core human challenge to try to see
yourself and to take other people's
input to learn how you impact those
around you I think we have a really
conflicted relationship with feedback in
other words most of us have had the
experience of having a mentor or a coach
or someone who taught us something
really valuable and we saw ourself
getting better at something quickly and
that is exhilarating we're so grateful
and yet all of us also have the
experience
of getting painful cutting unfair
off-base poorly delivered feedback that
not only wasn't helpful to us but was
actually damaging and I think that that
conflictual relationship really reflects
the fact that feedback sits at the
junction of two core human needs human
beings are wired to learn and grow if
you look at any of the studies
unhappiness getting better at something
is a key piece of what makes life
satisfying it's why we take up hobbies
in retirement and why otherwise normal
people stick with the game of golf right
because that occasional good round fools
us into thinking that we're getting
better but alongside that lies this
second core human need which is the need
to be accepted and respected and loved
just the way we are now and the very
fact of feedback suggests that how we
are now is not quite a okay and I don't
think that tension is going to go away
but understanding that that's why we
sometimes love it and sometimes really
hate it helps us understand why it's
part of the condition of being human
getting better at receiving feedback is
a skill and it actually gives you
traction in all of the important areas
of your life so at work what the
research shows is that people who
solicit negative feedback and in the
literature what that means is that
they're not just fishing for compliments
they're actually asking what could I
improve those people adapt more quickly
to new roles they report higher
satisfaction and they get higher
performance reviews so not only do they
actually accelerate their own learning
they also change the way other people
see them if you look at the marriage
research John Gottman up in Seattle who
studies marriage has found that a
spouses willingness to take input or
coaching from their partner is a key
indicator for happy stable marriages now
that's true even though most of us find
our spouses chronic complaints about our
character flaws you know we don't think
of them as feedback we think of them as
them being annoying but our willingness
to act
here that is key to the stability of the
marriage and you know and I think about
how I parent my kids you know the the
most important thing I can do is
actually show them how I respond to
setbacks at work or the criticism from
my mother-in-law that's going to do more
for how they respond to a bad grade or a
bad call in the baseball game then all
my lectures combined
you